if you're gonna tell new york city to go
screw itself you might as well do it in
mosaic in 1910 New York City was trying
to expand on a one-two-three line over
on seventh Avenue and they did this
through the always popular method of
eminent domain where they basically took
an 11 block chunk of land with 300
buildings on it and said yeah this is
ours now get out one of the tenants
David Hesse who owned a seven story
building called the Voorhees said he
didn't want to go and he fought New York
City in court and he lost he died not
long after and that would be the end of
the story except for the fact that his
children noticed that there was a tiny
triangle of land that had been
overlooked by the surveyors office and
technically this little triangle lot 55
was still there's this tiny triangle not
much larger than a slice of pizza and
what they did with it was they installed
a tiny mosaic plaque on it and the
plaque reads property of the Hess estate
which has never been dedicated for any
public purpose they basically just made
a little mosaic sign that said screw you
this is ours and we're never giving it
up to this day mosaic and all still
proudly telling New York to go screw
itself click here to subscribe
they did give it up eventually in 1938
they sold it to the local cigar shop
there's actually tiny little triangles
of orphan real estate scattered across
the city it's a nice little triangle
people walk all over it all the time
they don't know that it's there so what
do you think the world's greatest hidden
wonders are let me know in the comments
and I can't wait to hear all about them